so this is a marketplace now we have the
customers
that need to use the app but we also
have the restaurants
so let's here and let's try to listen
very carefully to the restaurants and
what are their concerns and let's try to
put
all of this in the india so this was
also one of the challenges like
having the the product so that everyone
like the both key stakeholders are both
happy
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance opposed labs touring
hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech welcome to another episode of 20
minute leaders this is a very very
special one it's actually a
two-in-one meet anna and belen the
co-founders of flip eat
two very enthusiastic 25 year old
friends from childhood with previous
experience in banking consulting and
amazon
who always knew they wanted to create a
business together they co-founded flippy
six months ago with the aim of creating
a more efficient restaurant reservation
process through digitalization
adding a social component which allows
to create a personalized network of
friends
to share culinary experiences and
recommendations
they are present in madrid and soon to
open in barcelona and marbella
and they aim to expand internationally
in the upcoming year anna and bellen
welcome to 20 minute leaders this is a
very historic moment we're doing here
how are you
hello michael nice to meet you and we
are really glad
that you invited us and feel really
honored to be in your little show
exactly thank you very much for having
us thank you
thank you where are you calling from
right now
well actually we're going from madrid
more specifically from our kitchen
so the most yeah it is as most
entrepreneur as it gets i guess
but madrid fun fact we have like 37
degrees already here
so yeah this is why we are looking like
this
we are currently melting well
this is a historic moment for me because
this is the first episode that i get to
do with two people at the same time
so i've gotten to practice a lot on one
person so excuse me for
you know for my uh you know amateurness
in in this next 20 minutes but it's
going to be a lot of fun
um so anna and bellen best friends for a
long time way before
flip eat you're launching now in madrid
and you're
and you're launching i believe in in a
new area soon and you're planning to go
international
uh so we will talk about flippit and
exactly what you're doing there
but before we do that i want to go back
to your partnership
and your friendship because that really
i think is a core part of the story take
you tell me a little bit about
your relationship and and and how that
led to you deciding to create a company
together
okay cool go ahead okay so basically
um belen and i know each other and we're
friends from childhood since about
when we were 14 or 15 years old and for
some reason since we know each other
we've always
known that we wanted to create something
together so when we were at university
at first we were really
um you know following kind of the same
path so we went on
internships together we were in london
sharing a bed sharing a room in london
another summer
and sharing a dream because we both
wanted to be like the most successful
investment bankers in london yeah this
was our first dream
but we said we very quickly realized
that that was not our path
yeah but we shared the the same dream
since the very beginning that we wanted
to be there in
in london in investment banking
and then we realized that that was not
our path and then we started dreaming
on the entrepreneurship area and that we
needed to
to found something that really motivates
us
and then yeah so basically
uh yes so basically we we've kind of
followed the same path but we always
knew
that at some point we will launch
something together build something
together
we never really knew what it was but we
knew that for sure it was going to be
together
and we were going to put a lot of effort
with technology
in the center it was also something that
we knew from the very beginning
yeah so after you know so after well
after spending quite a few summers uh
doing our
uh university in doing these internships
in investment banking some stuff
at the beginning when we finished uni we
kind of divided up with our past so
belen went into consulting she worked in
bain and company
i decided to go with amazon because we
were like okay we have to kind of divide
the knowledge we have right you go into
consulting i go into e-commerce and then
we go all part of the big plan yes that
this was really our plan
we need to divide our knowledge so you
better know a lot of
e-commerce and then you need to know a
lot of uh
more operational yeah exactly like
strategic skills
like we said okay you go this way and go
this way and then
again we we well
we go together to found this that we
didn't know
what was going to be until six months
ago
six months yeah six or seven months ago
then i received a call from
berlin uh it was right in the middle of
a
pov um where restaurants were starting
to open again etc
and then brain comes calls me and she's
she tells me
anna i got it i got the idea i know what
we're doing
listen up because it's happening and
this is the idea
i was like okay i'll be there five
minutes
and then she started teaching me about
this idea uh
of flip it um and it sounded
just so exciting and
obvious that it had to be made uh like
some sometimes you just think no
everything
is invented right like everybody's
thinking about things to invent
no no hang on listen up look for a
subject that you really like
and really think about how to make life
easier and much more simple
so basically flip it really can we
basically
we basically knew that it was going to
be something with technology but we
didn't know the other part and we
we we thought that restaurants that we
are
both like super super like i love being
in a restaurant because of the
atmosphere and having a beer and now
and having wine and like the
the like the social life and anna is
like
an obsessed woman on the product itself
like she loves
having like the best sushi and and she
really values this
this part of the restaurants that i the
economic part of it brother you know
like talking to a chef and learning
about techniques and stuff and ben is
more into the
ambience atmosphere cool places and
stuff so it's a pretty good thing but we
love
we both love restaurants so we we like
we started
thinking on this idea that it has
the two things that we like a lot not so
we have technology
and we have like the restoration
industry so we identified like a problem
here in spain that is basically that is
super difficult
like because everybody in spain at least
in spain we love
like uh going out and going to a
restaurant and meeting with a lot of
people and this is something
that in other countries for example it's
something a little bit more typical on
the weekend but here in spain
we can go on a tuesday to have a beer
and on a saturday
like restaurants are always full so we
identified this problem
that that it was like very very
frustrating yeah it was very frustrating
because uh
my family and i like every sunday we we
always go out and
we we normally go like try to go to a
restaurant
a cool restaurant that we like but it
was like super frustrating that we
needed to be like 20 minutes calling to
a lot of restaurants like
hello would you have a table for six
today at 2 p.m
no we are we are we are fully booked
sorry okay next one
so we already had tools here in spain
like for example one that is very
popular in europe
is um the fork or in the u.s open table
but we we didn't like we were not using
this app
and and well the reason behind we can
later talk about like the difference etc
but we we weren't using this uh app
so we identified this problem and then i
called anna like
let's do this we we have this problem we
can be like the solution to a lot of
people
and yeah this is how flip it started
yeah basically tell me this pollution
cool yes so basically so basically for
the solution as berlin was saying i
think that it's
something so so the problem is a social
component in which in spain
uh eighty percent of those reservations
are done two
and twenty and forty two hours before
the actual booking
other cultures are maybe more like kind
of uh prepared or they do things like in
advance but here in spain we don't
and this together with the fact that we
love going out and it's part of our
culture
uh supposed a problem for most of us
basically
as velen was saying the fact of having
to call 10 restaurants
when you uh want to go out to to find
availability so we thought okay how come
if i go for instance to barcelona for a
weekend
and play don't call 10 hotels to see
which one has a free bet
i just get into a platform which tells
me life availability of hotels
account for something so recurrent as
going out and eating out
we don't really have a solution with
let's say appealing restaurants because
you know you can't find many many any
other platforms in which you can find
a lot of restaurants but we didn't kind
of on one
in which you could find the cool
restaurants the ones that are in
fashionable the ones that are kind of
appealing in madrid it wasn't any
because because for some reason there
wasn't any i mean
the the current solutions that the
market was providing was not a kind of
fit for those type of restaurants
so we decided why don't we create a
platform which shows
live availability of restaurants in
madrid of cool restaurants invaded
not necessarily expensive because for
instance we have like
over 300 already we launched two weeks
ago and we have
over 300 restaurants and and yeah but
they are like
we have michelin star restaurants of 150
euro tickets but we also have like the
cool restaurants with a little terrace
on the side to have a little beer and a
little
no tortilla patata which we obviously
love and you know so it's
for all types of uh moments or
or kind of dates that you want to have
family friends everything
business even to find live availability
not only on a list but also on a map
hey we're around me can i find a cool
place just two people on a terrace
outside
you know i get to sit now with with both
co-founders
and usually i get to only talk to one it
can't
be that this vision and the idea in the
product
was obvious to the both of you a hundred
percent with no discrepancies
i'm i'm seeing here two and two women
who did two different paths
coming back together with a lot of ideas
how did you what were some of the
challenges along the way and how did you
work together to resolve those as
partners
uh many times i would say that one of
them
like the most difficult tasks is to
really divide
and conquer you know so imagine we have
like
in a day we have a problem which is
basically
that there are we like we identify that
we don't have as much restaurants
as we would like to have in the platform
okay
so then anna and i both we dedicate
we we like we spend our full day
trying to speak with different
restaurants and doing like the
commercial
the commercial speaking so we go to see
like
10 restaurants in a day and and that was
like very difficult
very difficult to like separate now so
if there is a problem
that is like today as of today this is
something that is on
bananas played like like the commercial
and the restaurant strategy is something
that is now on up but this is
something that we understood like one
week ago
because we were doing like both of us
the
the same tasks now so like the thing
the fact of having a lot of different
challenges in a day and a
a lot of problems in a day we like
we were thinking very like immediate and
very in a certain term now so this
problem this solution
and now we are like trying to every day
say okay belen this is like acquisition
and users acquisition is like my main
area where i am now trying to focus a
lot and anna
is doing the commercial so understanding
this
like was like super difficult because in
the same day we
we have three problems but but we were
both doing one
no like the most important one so this
is not the way to proceed and we have
very similar profiles because
anna is not like super techy and i am
not either no so we are both like the
we we can do the commercial pitch both
of us we can do the acquisition
like the marketing strategy we can do
like the two of us can do perfectly this
um
like these um tasks so dividing these
and and and and what i was saying at the
beginning like divide and conquer
this is something that like six months
that we were doing
a lot of the same things
and when we have like different like
different
yes different opinions what we do is
basically
yes what we do this is like we try to
um we try to have a conversation where
we say
okay these are the pros these are the
cons and then we try to
listen to our people that we trust
no so we have different advisors so okay
this is something important important
decision like we want to open in
barcelona
so at the beginning anna was saying i
think we need to open first in marbella
and i was like no
i i think barcelona so we do like the
pro and the cons then we
speak with the different advisors that
we have and
and we try to make the decision but
sometimes it's like
anna wins on these these questions and
others it's
something yes and also in terms
and then in terms of what challenges we
faced
rather selling not not our us as a
startup but rather
facing the public or as a product and i
think that
one of the one of the biggest challenges
was
for the restaurant to really understand
the value added of our product
right so there are two things that we
have to face first one is that here in
madrid as we were telling you
we didn't have any other product that um
was a platform with kind of a more
sophisticated
uh range of restaurants right so the
platforms that they were
were perceived for the restaurants are
as low
kind of uh or image
how can i say this in in a right way
kind of um
the the platforms that currently existed
were not so sophisticated but so for
more sophisticated restaurants they did
not want to be perceived in one of those
platforms
so one of the challenges that we had was
to kind of let them understand
that we were a different type of
platforms with with a much more
sophisticated type of restaurant
and then also we started to analyze
what other functionalities we could add
to our app that were differential to
other apps that already existed because
they
they used to tell us okay live
availability if you go into my website
you can see live availability okay right
so not only we are showing live
availability
of all restaurants but we have already
also developed
another part of the app which is
something that only flip it
as of today has which is a social part
so
so we really thought about how is the
process of
restoration on a regular on a regular
person right
and often we understood that we heard
that it was it started in
a group of friends hey guys can you
please recommend a cool sushi place or
or going into what's a group of friends
typical whatsapp group or friends or
like you will follow an
instagram kind of gastro foodie and you
will kind of see the recommendations
and stuff so we were like hey why but
i'm sorry yeah so you would ask for the
recommendation
the friend will tell you the
recommendation you will go into the
website see availability
color restaurant and book or book
through website how can we make this
shorter and quicker right so
what we developed is in our app there
are two kind of big parts the first one
it shows availability
but if you don't have like if you didn't
make up your mind yet then you know
where to go
you also have the social but in which
one kind of connects society and you can
follow
your friends and your people of
that you trust or gas draw any shelf or
anything and then you can see their
recommendations and you can only see
the recommendations of the people
precisely because you're interested in
their content now on the internet you
can find a lot of content
and also the people that you follow can
only comment or only recommend if they
book through the app and they go in this
way we are kind of making sure
that the opinions are truthful not like
we want to finish with fake opinions
that when we started talking with
restaurants
this was one of their main like concerns
like
tripadvisor is something that i can i
can go
or not go to a restaurant but i can have
an and like
buddha review and everyone can read this
review
but maybe i i didn't go to the
restaurant so
this is something that there are like
the restaurants started saying i was
like this is a very
like this is a very critical pain point
where you could
give us like a lot of value and be
different from other platforms
so we rapidly like integrate this and we
started this social part like okay so
let's
let's try to have our clients which we
would so this is a marketplace now we
have the customers
that need to use the app but we also
have the restaurants
so let's here and let's try to listen
very carefully to the restaurants and
what are their concerns and let's try to
put all of this in the
in the app so this was also one of the
challenges like
having the the product so that everyone
like the
both keys stakeholders are both happy
also taking into account that we are
like in our first mvp
which is a very kind of advanced ndp's
not like the usual mvp
but we are like our main goal now is for
everyone to try us
and sit down both with users and
restaurants and kind of understand their
necessities and adapt
really quickly and people we know we're
going to people a lot so for instance if
a restaurant tells us
okay i really would enjoy this
functionality or if you could offer this
service or you could have put a button
doing this and that that's our main goal
you know sit down
really understand how we can help and
how we can
add real value to both the restaurant
and the customer always taking into
account that you know
customer obsession at the next amazonian
i have it here i wake up every day
customer obsession customer obsession
uh but yes we are now in the face of
trying
understanding and further developing new
functionalities
and then as you probably imagine what
you want to do like
a lot of things because you want to
listen and have everyone
like everyone needs to be happy no so
then okay let's do everything that we
we want to do so the next challenge is
obviously technology no because
technology is like
super super like something that goes
much slower than you always expect so
this is something this is probably the
the talent
today like we would love to have like a
um like different functionalities that
we don't have yet
and this is something because of
technology like there are
there is a lot of testing and and
programming and a lot of
like okay this functionality is not
exactly what we meant
we were we were thinking more of this so
a lot of
testing and a lot of backs obviously
the other day my kid is gonna know
how to program before even learning
english i swear
well i i can definitely agree with that
with that idea
yeah i think i think it's a it's a huge
huge really important skill it's not the
only skill that you need to succeed
obviously you definitely need the the
commercial side and you need the product
side and the customer obsession side
otherwise programming it doesn't
actually do us any good
but 20 minutes go by very very fast and
and i really want to thank you for
coming and sharing your journey
it's really really inspiring for me you
know hearing about these these you know
early stages
and and obviously the the relationship
that you have both as friends but also
as
co-founders it's very it's it's very
unique in the sense i
most of the co-founders that i meet
there weren't necessarily best friends
for 10 15 years
the idea that you had this plan one
going to be going to amazon
and and gaining different skills coming
back together and
completing each other i think that
that's just very very cool and i wish
you best of luck
with everything you're doing i have a
few more last questions
uh and and i'm going to ask you each of
you to answer
about your own and then the last one
we'll we'll do it a fun different
game but first anna we'll start with you
and then belen
somebody that inspires you along the way
a role model of some sort cool um
i think that there are many people that
inspire me
uh but i think that i have my answer 100
ready
maybe it's a weird answer but it's my
grandfather
for sure always and forever my
grandfather is the person that
inspired me most personally and
professionally and it's something that i
always think about before making any big
decisions
i'm gonna be cheesy but you know this is
how i am
and me too so i would say i would
probably say my parents
and in this interview specifically my my
father because he is a very
well i consider him a successful man but
he maintains his
or he remains his personality as he was
like 20 years ago
um and specifically very humble
which is like probably the the addictive
to me
like the most important going back to
your childhood
what was your what was the passion of
yours or
something that really you know that you
are really excited by whether in school
or outside of school
um when i was in school i went to a
friend
a french school and and i remember
that physics was my passion and my dream
from the age of 11 until the age of
15 was to become a physics teacher i
didn't want to be anything else just
physics teacher and having a flower shop
in the future
which i will have for sure
um i would probably say
history like as a subject in in school
like it's something that i i loved in
particular this second
world war like i i read a lot of books
and it's something super weird but i
i still like read a lot of
of the same books like i don't know why
but it's something like super
like fascinating to me so i was not any
sport
you didn't want to be and and yes and i
was like super supportive yes very
probably skin like i wanted to be a a
teacher
and live six months in argentina
and yeah now i i'd like you to say three
words that you would
use to describe the other person so
anna what are three words that you would
use to describe velen with
okay so
i would say be careful
okay i would say that she is
very humble which is something i i
admire a lot from her and i learn every
day
i myself i am not so humble so it's
something that i really enjoy having
around and learning from
i would say that she is very perseverant
you know very persevered which is really
helpful
in our job and and i would say
the third one which is the most real
like the most real objective objective
of the about ballen
is charming she has like a natural charm
everything like she says and how she
says it and like it's like
you just get charmed by her so this is
one of the objectives maybe she's not
i'm right now
but she's naturally charming
so i would say thank you very much for
that
and i would say she's
of course extroverted as you can
probably see
so extraverted which is something super
important and this is why
anna is always in the street going to
see like
many restaurants because she has the
perfect commercial
um personality uh so extroverted i would
say
um forward thinker like
she thinks a lot in the future and like
in medium
and long-term objectives and thinking on
these
like objectives she organizes for day to
day
so this is super important of course in
in a startup
and then i would say
like same one common it's perseverant no
like
she's like very hard worker and and
and well and i think she she will
achieve anything that she wants to
thank you so much for joining me thank
you
very very much best of luck on your
journey both as
you know co-founders but also with the
business and thank you for coming stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you thank you very much
for having us
[Music]